yeah it's a giant bubble I didn't
explain it to him I didn't feel like it
[Music]
there's a lot about living in a city I
love but I really really hate going
through Times Square for the tourists
everywhere it's crowded it's like movies
with seas of bodies not to mention
trying to get on the subway and some
trains are delayed and it's just like
hot and sweaty and there's so many
people and we're all trying to squeeze
on the train and especially you have a
female you're a little smaller it's
harder to take up space I saw an
Instagram this video of a game called
zorbing with his people running around
in these giant plastic bubbles and I
thought I'm going to reclaim my personal
space by dunking this body in a giant
plastic bubble I'm gonna talk to people
see if they think it's a good idea yeah
I know some people will think it's
extreme and some people think it's
stupid and to those people I say I
already bought it so I'm gonna do it I
guess if I get hit by a car I'll
probably just bounce off
that's also an ice skate service Here I
am I'm inside the ball alright I think
I've got control of my personal space
level I think I'm good enough to go
outside so I got the ball we're trying
to get it down an elevator then we have
to make it through a door though I'm
trying to take up too much space in this
world that's nice
we're gonna have to deflate it let's do
it dude the door gets smaller the ball
is outside and I'm going to reclaim my
personal space in the city let's go
no one's touching me he's businessman I
want and strength
like Moses parting the Red Sea how much
for the mangoes
thank you
good I think now I should try to talk to
people who cut dammit
what about like Times Square it's really
touristy it's hard to move around
everyone navigate your way through I'm
gonna try to hail a cab to go to Times
Square I don't really like being boxed
in either yeah you just gotta like push
yourself through the crowd yeah
gives you used to the half mr. silly
people and it was really hard to breathe
and move all right I don't think that
cabs gonna pick us up I brought this all
upon myself I made myself put this on
this was my choice do you guys think
this is a good solution to reclaim my
personal space yeah I like it yeah
that's good I mean you're drawing
attention to your home too so if you're
okay with that then it's an awesome idea
a distance of people yeah yeah reclaim
my space
no one's gonna sit next to me because I
have this giant bubble on so what's the
worst thing about the city what do you
hate about this correct they got to get
rid of the rats the rats are like
everywhere and then you got to remember
like people are sitting up there and
trying to get on the train before you
get off the train and it's like lady are
you serious you're 50 years old you
don't know come on you want me to knock
it down oh my goodness is just right
when I get crowded you know people
bumping into you
wow I just bumped me they don't say
sorry another that this wall right past
you keep going oh my gosh is this big
enough for me
I think I have to give up thank you so
much that was so nice so the best way to
like people just what to stay out of my
space and just give them a mean stare
like you can just be loud and like
sounds like kind of scary people wear
face masks yeah we all wear those people
would give each other more space women
take up space taking up space bar room
oh yeah sure oh my god that's a sad I
can't hug I just realized I can't hug if
you want personal space you don't get
hugs the lessons I've learned you guys a
plastic bubble physically gives me more
personal space but it's not worth the
trouble
physically I had this on so nobody could
like touch me or rub up against me which
was great but they also couldn't hug me
that really made me sad
[Music]